[Music]
okay it's certainly a great pleasure to
be back here at MIT and l1s I was here
for exactly one decade four years as an
undergraduate working with Bill four
years as a graduate student working with
Bill two years as a postdoc working with
Bill somebody said gee to me yesterday I
think it was Bob Jaffe that was an
awfully long sentence but but I didn't
consider it that way it was always been
a pleasure and I think the remark that
Fred made about Bill I think is probably
characterizes a the experience better
than I could which we said that talking
about the spectrometer bill wanted this
particular design people told him he
couldn't have it Bill got it anyway and
it worked out just fine and I think we
that was a good lesson that I learned
from how to do practice in the world of
physics from Bill so I want to talk
about some things that have been done
some things that are just are being done
and some focus on where we're going with
electrons both around the world but
mainly with the emphasis on Bates and
it's Sheba and I'll break it up into
sort of two sections one dealing with
nuclei proper and the other dealing with
the nucleon itself both of which are
receiving extensive attention the first
part one might subtitle as a particle
physics meets the many-body problem and
there are certain issues that I'll go
into where the nucleon itself which is a
sort of a particle physics object it
straight meets directly aspects of the
many-body problem and in particular this
is the question of nucleon structure in
nuclei if those nucleons are modified it
is certainly because of their the
presence of the many-body environment
say something about the phenomenon of
color transparency and correlations and
then I want to talk about three aspects
of low-energy QCD that are receiving a
lot of attention these are the electric
form factor of the neutron the
excitation of the nucleon to the Delta
and the strange quark content of the
Leon I'll just very briefly flashed this
since bill laid out a lot of this
groundwork what makes the whole new
generation of studies possible of course
is the technical advancement of the new
facility this new facilities the single
most important being the continuous
beams but there's many others high
intensity access to internal targets
with tens of millions of circulating
current polarization observables and
both large acceptance and out-of-plane
detection of reaction products so let's
start with nucleons and nuclei first
question one might ask is are they in
there and the answer is to some extent
sure because one sees the incoherent
coherent scattering from nearly free
constituents which tells us that the
nucleus is composed of nucleons the next
question one might ask then is are they
the same as the nucleons you get when
you buy a bottle of hydrogen and the
answer is no at some levels and let's
talk I want to show four results that
relate to these these two questions the
first are they in there we saw some of
this helpful data but one does indeed
see quite nicely begin in the in the
unseparated cross-section the throughout
the periodic table from carbon to nickel
to lead this structure that is the
Doppler broadening
early Fermi gas calculations by and at
the time young emo knees and everything
appears here to be under control in the
sense that at that time this is data
from the early 70s you see the quasi
elastic structure it has the right
quantitative strength the nucleus is
composed of quasi free nucleons however
once these data were separated into
their longitudinal and transverse
components one sees there's many ways to
represent this problem one way is to
represent it in terms of the so called Y
scaling variable which in a first
approximation is the nucleons
longitudinal momentum in the initial
State
and when you divide out the appropriate
nucleonic response one would expect a
universal response that that is what
these the data should scale as a
function of this single variable and the
several momentum transfers plotted here
one sees that they indeed do scale in
terms of that variable but the deviation
from our simple Simo simple idea which
would say that these two response
functions is scale equally and once
these that they do not the television
people would like you to stand in the
limelight
oh-ah TV so there's one problem in our
understanding that may be related to the
question of nucleons and nuclei I will
say a little more about it let me just
quickly remind you of the the first EMC
effect the ratio of the response
function and a heavy system to deuterium
and in particular one sees throughout
this intermediate x region where X is
now as the longitudinal momentum carried
by the struck fork this degradation and
remembering that these two that what
this structure functions are are the
quark momentum distributions this
degradation or at an intermediate X says
that there are fewer quarks with those
higher momentum values meaning longer
range correlations so in in some sense
there are many mechanisms proposed of
course to account for the emc effects
but they all share the feature that they
do have look that the quarks have longer
correlation lengths inside the nucleus
and in some sense that certainly is new
many body modification of the nerve
structure of the nucleon in the nucleus
another place where that might be
relevant return again to the Coulomb sum
rule which as dirk indicated measures
essentially the charge of the nucleus
and a two proton correlation term which
one expects to at least get small if not
go to 0 as the momentum transfer
increases and i remind you of two
results at both abate since that
a very detailed studies were done on the
few body systems on and in tritium one
sees that it goes to the value Z equals
one quite nicely and on helium three and
four
it's either converged or nearly
converged to the value Z equals two when
one goes to heavy systems essentially
all heavy systems with the possible
exception of uranium indicate this quite
sizable suppression that the Dirk
alluded to of the longitudinal response
and it's much larger than it can be
realistically expected from the effects
of correlations so one suggestion that
was made and sort of gets back to the
EMC is maybe the longer core correlation
length manifests itself as truly an
increased radius this is the the swollen
nucleons hypothesis these things get
bigger you construct this some rule by
dividing out the free proton form factor
so if the nucleon was larger in the
medium the form factor would be dropping
faster and that you would make therefore
an error in in dividing that out that's
a simple-minded picture one question
then is are these two effects our EMC
and this deviation from our simple ideas
in the quasi elastic region related
that's certainly not a question that I'm
prepared to answer or I think has been
answered let me just show you kind of a
list of the things that people have
thought about in response to these
questions that the nucleus exhibits an
increased radius and magnetic moment in
the medium by various mechanisms
renormalized vector Maison masses is a
and and vacuum polarization involving
vector maisons and the in a sort of
vector Maison dominance picture has been
popular the idea of pi on excess and
nuclei that there is there are more pi
ons per nucleon in a nucleus because in
addition to the vert the loops that
connect the nucleon to itself one now
has the possibility of maize on exchange
quark exchange between two nucleons as
they pass by it's certainly in a loud
process for them to share too
exchange quarks which gives then on the
average a larger length scale for those
quarks to wander around and that's just
sort of the one example of the whole
class of topics partial D confinement
where the quarks are free to wander from
nucleon the nucleon or at least amongst
neighboring nucleons giving you the so
called six quart bags to the extreme
limit where they would be free to wander
through the entire nucleus that is it
would percolate how am I to attempt to
look for this well there's been -
there's been several I will talk about -
experimental attempts one is to measure
the momentum transfer dependence of the
proton knock out reaction which we if we
believe that we are interacting with a
nearly free proton in in in inside the
nucleus then the momentum transfer
dependence should be that of the free
nucleon cross-section and the other
approach is to measure the longitudinal
transverse character of that same
cross-section well you know you're only
knocking out a single proton and and
going to a bound state of the residual
system so both these types of
experiments have been done at Nick F and
here at Bates it's easier to cover a
wider range of momentum transfer just
measuring the cross-section and one sees
it for carbon knock out that within the
error bars both for P shell knock out
from the P shell of carbon and the S
shell of carbon over a pretty wide range
of momentum transfer almost up to a GeV
squared where the nucleon form factor
has changed by more than an order of
magnitude over this range to within the
about the 15% level these data are flat
we have divided out parted as a
spectroscopic factor but what that means
is we've divided out the free nucleon
response so what these data are telling
you are at the level of their errors the
response versus momentum transfer of a
proton in carbon looks like the free one
one can then put limits on how much the
radius could change on the basis of
these data and it's about 15% and
certainly one hopes one expects that
with a hundred percent duty factor and
more intensity these these error bars
will over the next several years be
brought down considerably the other way
to look at this is to look at this
so-called this ratio RG which for a free
nucleon turns out to just be the ratio
of GMP over GE P which is the magnetic
moment of the proton to point seven nine
and that's indicated by the horizontal
line here this has been measured at knee
calf and one point at Bates and one sees
that over a more modest momentum
transfer range a slight deviation for
these several nuclei and shells from the
free space value but I indicate that
this once one does real DWI a
calculations of this and puts in the
proton distortion and some differential
effects that are totally conventional
these data are those effects are
consistent with these data so there is I
think I end that section just echoing
Dirk's remark this the this question of
at intermediate energies of the
longitudinal transverse response the
suppression of the Coulomb sum rule
remains an important open question on
the one hand and we certainly haven't
seen in the same energy region any any
smoking gun signature for nucleon
modification in the medium and to the
although we've looked nucleons when we
knock them out of the nucleus well the
kind of things I was just talking about
were related to initial state properties
the final state may also be quite
interesting in particular there's been a
prediction now that's been around for
quite a while because the phenomenon of
color transparency it's a prediction of
perturbative qcd that in there's that
there's a lack of absorption and hadron
nucleus interactions at high q squared
you basically need three things to
happen for this to be true you need to
produce small objects at high q squared
basically the spatial extent of the
object being roughly 1 over Q then those
smaller objects have to have small
cross-sections basically because they
will have a small colored dipole moment
and then those objects have to get out
of the nucleus before they expand
because if you say knock out a proton
that
we're initially the three courts were
quite close together it's gonna blow up
until it and when a by the time it's
reached its asymptotic state your
detector so if those conditions are met
one might expect to see a dramatic
effect in nuclei let me just show you
what the how what the effect might be
here's the picture of what the q squared
dependence is based on this cartoon at
high Q squared it's a it moves further
out before it expands the red circle is
of course the nucleus so you would
expect increased transparency as you go
to higher q squared
wow it fixed Q squared you would expect
more transparency for a small nucleus
than a big one and those that general
feature of course of course borne out by
all the more detailed calculations of
which I show one here you see the
decreasing transparency as a gets bigger
and the increasing transparency as as
the momentum gets higher now this is
would be a unambiguous detection of this
would certainly be of great interest
there are several experimental
initiatives there is data somewhat
controversial to explain at the moment
on p2p at Brookhaven which I won't talk
about at all
beyond that there is AE prime P data
from slack experiment any 18 that is
currently under analysis that the data
is all been taken and we should know an
answer on that before too awful long and
there are proposals for more of this at
slack going to higher momentum transfer
as any 18 went to about 7 GeV squared
they want to double that and both EE
prime P and also EE prime P with
polarization at somewhat lower momentum
transfers at C bath let me just quickly
show you so just the rule some
preliminary results although not the Q
squared dependence of the slack
experiment but to someone has done
coincidence experiments at a at 1% Duty
the fact that they get these data at 10
to the minus 4 Duty I think is really
quite impressive you see missing energy
spectra on carbon at a Jeb squared the P
and s shell structures cleanly seen no
background beneath the nucleon threshold
and probably the most impressive picture
is
at seven Jeff squared we're even and
under those extreme conditions low
cross-section exceeding low duty factor
they obviously still get a very nice
clean signal out of there and we
certainly look forward to the results of
that experiment at sea bath let me show
you one projected result there's the
there's the standard one wants to look
in carbon and oxygen and so forth and
the standard picture showing the no no a
globe or treatment of the final state
interactions which are essentially
energy independent and then the kind of
size of effect you'd expect from color
transparency the interesting thing about
this one proposal is that in addition to
exploiting high resolution so that even
in the hallway set up so that you can
even separate the p3 halves in p1 half
shell in oxygen it will also attempt to
measure the the component of proton
polarization in the final state normal
to the reaction plane in plane wave
impulse approximation that is if the
proton had no further interactions with
the nucleus this component is
identically zero it's like the fifth
response function that Bill Church and
that's alluded to an observable that is
rigorously zero in the absence of final
state interactions is therefore a quite
sensitive probe of those final state
interactions and it will be quite
interesting to measure both the
cross-section and this and the momentum
transfer dependence of this induced
polarization simultaneously there was a
crucial assumption that goes into
essentially all the previous slides in
particular the picture also of the color
transparency prediction that the that
the scattering results from a one
interaction with a one body current that
is that all the energy and momentum of
the photon is absorbed on a single
nucleon there's a serie been a series of
experiments at Bates it's that clay Andy
keV that reveal the limitations of this
concept one sees for example the
interaction with two nucleon pairs that
is a deuteron like object in the ground
states of helium three and four one sees
an additional component to the
transverse response function that's
associated with the two nucleon
threshold even when you sit right on top
of the quasi elastic peak that is at x
equals one and to my mind anyway these
are the most dramatic data that
indicates this effect it was the thesis
work of Palmer this is the missing
energy spectrum on carbon the
longitudinal response the one P and the
one s structure and then zero out here
and just a quick glance shows you how
qualitatively different the transverse
response function is excess strength o2
the deepest missing energies that were
measured are obviously still the s
structure present but there's clearly
something present that's at the moment
not understood quantitatively something
present in the transverse response
that's definitely not there in the
longitudinal if you look at the
difference between the two it rises up
from two nucleon threshold that that's
where that excess strength starts
increasing and that subsequently been
confirmed by Nick F measurements on a
couple of nuclei this strength out in
the continuum seems to grow and grow as
other experiments of Bates have revealed
the particular thesis work a Larry
Weinstein and John Morrison as one looks
at the strength and the missing energy
continuum versus Q squared it starts to
rise up it may become flat it's hard to
say on the basis of three points but it
comes up from numbers around 30% to
numbers of order 40% that's 40% of the
cross-section in the deep missing energy
continuum in processes that are
presently not understood and and so one
has to be quite careful about
interpreting missing energy spectra in
terms of just one one or of body
responses
and the questions that are that the
initiatives will address here bill also
had those up I phrase them just a little
bit differently how does the hadronic
committee body system absorb the energy
and momentum of a virtual Photon what is
the role of multi nucleon currents and
what are the role of sub nucleonic
degrees of freedom with the ultimate
goal of finding the limits to a
conventional Maison baryon description
now I want to switch from nuclei to a
nucleus the nucleus of hydrogen and talk
about things that go beyond the
Constituent quark model if the nucleus
was nucleus if the proton were we're
really just U and D quarks in a
spherically symmetric su6 wavefunction
there are three things that would be
rigorously zero one is the electric form
factor of the neutron the second are the
quadrupole components of the end to
Delta transition and the third
essentially by definition is the strange
quark content of the nucleon so those
are three things if they're nonzero
require us to go beyond this let's talk
about the neutron electric form factor
first its derivative at low Q squared is
the Neutron charge radius squared that
charge radius is measured quite
accurately scattering the thermal
neutrons from atomic electrons to have
this number it's not it's a negative
meaning there's more charge more
negative charge at big are in the
neutron it's positive in the center and
for comparison I show this the proton
radius here at you take the square root
the neutron radius is not small it's 16%
of that of the proton and the neutron
form factor it's not being nonzero
telling you how the deviations from
symmetry in those quark wave functions
it's a sensitive probe court
configurations it's also difficult to
measure because it is small in the
cross-section occurs quadrat it occurs
quadratically and sums with the large
magnetic form factor squared so what one
wants is observable is that a linear in
GE n and that means going to
polarization studies there are several
prospects and techniques for attacking
GE n
couple of which have already been
developed and used at Bates in initial
what I call proof of principle studies
these are the scattering of polarized
electrons from polarized helium-3 in two
different groups with two different
targets and the neutron spin transfer
that Dirk mentioned working at
relatively low Q squared in these
initial experiments that develop the
technology and showed yes indeed these
things can be done this way under
development are polarized solid state
targets nd three at Virginia and
Deuteronomy beam source for blast at
Wisconsin the next generation of
experiments will try to cover Q
Squared's up to about 0.6 GeV Square
debates and maybe two GeV squared C bath
with uncertainties of order 10 to 10 to
15% let me show you what the current
situation is old data now here are the
two measurements from Bates on the
polarized helium-3 and the neutron
recoil polarization which is preliminary
only point I want to make here is that
both these measurements were very
statistics limited the techniques work
they've been demonstrated and one hopes
to achieve the kind of error bars one
really wants to see 10 to 15% and
basically a little more current a little
more beam time but there's no question
that these methods are feasible and
what's on the table for the next round
of experiments would give error bars
like that based on a couple of different
models but here is here are two more
bates points using the South Hall ring
see BAFF points using the recoil
polarization and see both points using
the polarized deuterium target and this
once this program is complete and maybe
the end of the late late this century
will made a cold tremendous difference
in our knowledge of the neutron form
factor there are also will be attacked
with polarized internal targets and the
blast detector that bill showed both
polarized helium-3 and polarized
deuterium and I show the projected error
bars
and the results of several either
parameterizations of the Neutron form
factor or the case when it's zero and in
all cases once these large sensitivity
in these in the measured asymmetries to
to GE n and and it's certainly important
because one has to go to a nucleus to
get the neutron target to do this
recoil neutron detection polarized
helium-3 polarized deuterium will all
give us confidence than what we're
seeing is G en and and not maybe nuclear
physics let's turn to the end the Delta
transition in the quark model su six
quark model this is the spin flip of a
single s 1/2 quark so you have giving
you a spin three half state just a
single quark spin flip which would mean
the transitions pure magnetic dipole but
for example colored the color hyperfine
interaction that results from a1 glue on
exchange potential among other things
can give D state components in the in
the nucleon and Delta wave function very
much an analogy to the way the tensor
force gives D state components and the
deuteron wave function and that would
allow non zero Coulomb and electric
quadrupole amplitudes having D stayed in
there that there might be a significant
D state in there was suggest a long time
ago by glass out to resolve some
problems in the simple quark model had
will say calculating the axial vector
coupling constant the F to D ratio and
more recently it's been suggested that
these D state components are relevant
for the role of quark angular momentum
contributions to the spin structure
functions there are the same exact same
remarks about quadrupole components
apply as I made for the neutron they're
sensitive they're difficult and you need
some observables linear in them to to
get at them
there are Dirk showed one picture of the
e to the C t2 is actually known a little
less a little worse than the c2 here you
see that the existing data don't even
really agree on the sign whereas the the
Coulomb quadrupole although with large
error bars
at least seems to favor a value around
maybe - five - seven percent of the
these are parted as ratio to the dipole
there are several initiatives to look at
n to Delta
both at baits using polarized electrons
and recoil proton polarization and
polarized electrons and out of plane
detection of the protons these will be
quite complementary studies and a sea
bath of course to extend to higher
momentum transfers the same technique
with polarized protons and also
polarized proton targets in class and
unpolarized measurements covering
covering a very wide range of momentum
transfers and when all the CBF
experiments are done one might hope to
go from this to cases like that where
the larger points result from the recoil
polarization and those are the same
class points that the Dirk showed how am
i doing time oh well let me I got a
couple of 292 more slides let me do I
gotta say something about parity it's
the lab the last I won't be motivated so
much to strange quark content to the
nucleon we expect that there is some are
some strange quarks in there on the
basis of say pioneer on Sigma the
polarized EMC and simple cartoons like
so which where you can have SS bar
components mixed in in a quark gluon
picture or even in a more conventional
picture you can have linked proton
fluctuations in two lambda K say all of
these things can give you a strange
quark component and the nucleon you
access it by one way to access it is by
parity violating electron scattering on
the proton just to you use the Z zero as
a probe of the hydronic structure and
the important point is that there isn't
a contribution to the electric part
that's seen by the Z that comes from
strange quarks and similarly for the
magnetic by combining the photon and the
z0
you make the ulema string
core contribution explicit it shows up
explicitly in the asymmetry so you
measure that asymmetry there's many
initiatives to measure that asymmetry I
me to say what the initiatives are and
then go to my last slide the initiatives
based on two facts one is that the
strange quark content has unknown loki's
that means radius and contribution to
the magnetic moment and it also has an
unknown Q squared dependence the sample
experiments at Bates is looking at very
backward angles at low Q squared the
goal thing to go after the strangeness
contribution to the magnetic moment mu
strange
haleh it's seabass it will use forward
angle scattering try to make very
precise measurements using the existing
high-resolution spectrometers over this
momentum transfer range there's a
proposed new detector for hall C at C
baths that would make could go lower at
4 go to low Q squared at forward angles
and also then be used for useful for at
backward angles to try to separate the
electric and magnetic strangeness
contributions and finally there was a
proposal being prepared for n station a
at SLAC that would use with high energy
electrons and forward angle 2 to look at
this so my last slide is just if I can
actually push every parity violating
electron scattering proposal or
experiment that's currently under the
underway they actually all fit on one
slide in the green curve is the standard
model calculation with no strange quarks
and the black curve in each case is the
fit of Bob Jaffe probably extended to Q
squared where it has no business being
extended to we see sample over here we
see C F R the hall C forward angle
measurements here the hallway
measurements here C bath backward angle
measurements here and finally at the
highest case of the highest momentum
transfers the slack measurements and in
each case the deviation from the
appropriate curve so what final remark I
want to make about this picture in
addition this is a decade of very nice
physics if it gets done we learn a
tremendous amount new window on the
nucleon
with the week neutral current and all
these experiments aim for reasonable
precision and I note that the at least
one of the co spokesmen on every one of
these experiments is either that his
thesis at MIT LS or was a postdoc at LNS
and I think that carries on the spirit
of the laboratory and a fine way to take
it to this new probe of the nucleon and
to have every experiment coming from
someone who had an association with the
laboratory at one time hey thank you
[Applause]